- All right. We always like
to end on a high note so that,
see what we did there 'cause
I'm a singer. We're clever.
So here's (chuckles)
one social media story
you can't miss.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(Kelly laughs)
Lots of musicians feed off the power
of playing for huge audiences.
But a banjo player in Colorado
has discovered the power
of playing for just one.
His admirer: a wild Fox, who
often trots over to listen
while the man picks and
strums his bluegrass stylings.
(man playing banjo)
- (exclaims) What!?
Like, this is crazy to me.
I have been in the wild,
and they run from you.
Foxes run from you,
they're like, "Oh human."
Like, you know what I'm saying?
They run. That's crazy.
We have this mesmerizing banjo
player on the line right now.
What's up Andy?
(audience claps)
- What's up Kelly?
- I mean, literally been,
I've been like in Alaska
in like remote of remote,
all places and foxes run,
you try and get a picture
of those guys they just run from you.
You are serenading one.
I don't know how that happened.
It's crazy. So, and this
happened a few times now, right?
Not just once.
- This has. It's been really amazing.
We're really lucky to
live on a couple acres
up in the Boulder foothills.
So there's a lot of space
for animals to roam around.
And I'm usually on tour a lot
with my band Leftover Salmon,
but when the pandemic hit,
we were home all the time.
And I just sit on the deck,
playing banjo every day and
one day the Fox wandered over
and we thought, "Wow, I think
he's really loving the music."
(Kelly chuckles)
And then another day I
was on a rock in the yard
and he literally came
and sat right next to me
and just stared at me while I played banjo
and it was the coolest thing.
- [Kelly] It is amazing.
- [Andy] And when my wife
finally captured it on
phone and we posted it,
people loved it.
And now we've put a few videos up.
We actually named the little guy Foxy too.
(both laugh)
- That's awesome.
- [Andy] He was like, "Boo."
- Did you say that your band's
name is Leftover Salmon?
- That's right.
- That's an amazing band name.
You said that like so
flippantly and I was like,
"No, we're going to talk about it."
That's an amazing band name.
Y'all gotta check out Leftover Salmon.
Thank you so much, Andy. I'm
liking your posts right now.
- [Andy] Thank You.
- All right. That's not all my man.
Our season long partner,
Pilot pen: makers of friction,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly, just like you.
So they're going to give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience claps)
- Amazing?
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh my God.
- I love you, Andy. (laughs)
This is awesome.
Thank you so much, Andy.
Keep playing for the Foxes.